how's it going bros my name is Pam
welcome to another a piece a would have
this a fake it would he be able to he's
continued back don't hit women
okay I want to go to one of the shops
they sell like a really good juice that
for whatever god damn it what was that
question I wasn't paying attention I am
okay we need to mean the bench is that a
snake that does not look like a snake is
it a dire snake oh yeah hey said I just
think I this snake then we're fine
[Music]
it's so good
I've got bigger things to deal with like
white seriously I like white let's meet
this Pope or whatever it is I don't know
I'm sorry but if you ask me the
deadliest catch is welcome to the shop
can I interest you in my ass yes I want
this one [ __ ] yeah all right let's talk
to him Canada is a monarchy but there's
other people with opinions by God sorry
God praise God praise God praise God and
God shut off sorry thank you I guess
that's it that's it
I want to try this out now actually
first sir concise yeah that feels
appropriate oh damn oh [ __ ] he has a lot
of help this might not be so easy magic
without
make me proud Cartman what is it
don't fire on the man's balls oh come on
he almost did it
oh god it's disgusting
all right now we attack his false
Hartman does a lot of damage it's
awesome
what is it oh come on all right we're
gonna have to finish him
yeah all right
wait the idiot okay we'll never know I'm
alive please take these diet pills and
tell the press they might okay well
bless you my son it'll be our secret Wow
good thing I saved these so we have
extra all right let's take them anyway
love thy neighbor so we can transcribe
pear-cut
hey Scott we can't okay Charlotte sup
great that again no damn
[Music]
I can make myself a nice tie now
religion won't interfere with government
how can we ever repay you you said you
would free the Minister of Montreal my
lord
sorry no can do with both the bishop and
the minister taking care of my throne is
to care but my liege we made a promise
you aren't you gonna queef
Thank You
[Laughter]
a Prince's ladder why
[Music]
okay Vancouver okay
I've really got to pee but I don't want
to take it right all right but Ottawa is
clear on the other side of Canada how we
supposed to get there what the why
according to this the prince had
something to do with the Bishop's murder
and has imprisoned the minister unjustly
young man if you wish to brave the
catacombs of Quebec you would have to
speak with the monks who live to the
southeast of town only they could train
you in such sorcery
speak the demonics okay what the [ __ ]
are we doing serious what the [ __ ] is
that girl doing many wonderful films are
shot in Vancouver it's down here
[Music]
yes heard it
Oh tears of it awesome everyone calling
this town magic roundup one aina
spotting hey nose tracking shiny any
Magician's apprentice can dragon shouts
it's not like you fathered into his hand
and hit you in the face with it fits
really good how come you can't sneak a
fraud behind your back he is worthy of
our training out there are we gonna get
another one what what are entering the
matrix it's just the right way to change
it spells frequency some objects seem
too large to be damaged by magic but now
I will break through it with Nagasaki
yeah okay
[Music]
[Applause]
now guys that I had it
see you said pedophiles I knew it now I
got sake [ __ ] I got [ __ ] thanks
that's fun and don't ever ever come at
me I always wanted to use my anus for
the greater of mankind for the good of
mankind
I'm so glad my teams are finally coming
true Pocky beer
ooh that's close all right this is our
Nagasaki
if a bomb amazing oh that's a lot of
them this is not gonna be easy man
hey oh [ __ ]
oh damn oh cool
definitely it's like the lead to pain
no said look at that damage me magic
missile
oh damn that was actually good I
finished some cod bed
use your cat who activates his reach
okay I gotta try this okay they have the
one is better this should finish him
that [ __ ] sound man damage you're on
fire that's what you are AM wasn't even
here before yes
nice pants dude okay we had [ __ ]
orcas right there crest completed Oh
Canada
barbarian armor right
new message I hope it's a queef you are
trying on Canada thank you I am bring
the test lateness to any I forgot why
exactly we were doing all this [ __ ]
music are they
[Music]
that's awesome I love this soundtrack oh
that mutant movie alright thank you
add another Canada let's keep going
south then so stupid for not realizing
that wait are we here now oh you could
walk this way in another ah ow
yes that is all I got we couldn't just
like [ __ ] Google Translate that [ __ ]
yes five women were at the clinic that
day and right there it says Nancy Turner
3:30 p.m.
[Music]
[ __ ] the evidence is irrefutable
thanks new kid we now know it was Heidi
Turner all along with spreading the
rumors but Heidi's really sorry so we're
deciding to forgive her I love you guys
so much sunshine girls are [ __ ] scary
man like I know they're just making fun
bet I could see some truth in whatever
was going on there okay so we can stay
here now jemelle gear man Oh
phallic here I'm not gonna wear that as
the girls I know it's my rub and my hair
[ __ ] yes yes I would love oh my god
bunnyears opponents are more likely to
attack allies stupid spoiler it's
awesome
[ __ ] yeah man that
fairy princess Rome so it wasn't there
all along huh
that I did did we return back to
yes here Oh fire temperature air why do
they look so pissed off what is it
I guess this means we're friends for now
but I still don't like your new kid okay
hey come in who's been where's a girl I
got a message sleepover yes all right
how the Pirates and the Federation
factions are standing by to fight as
well my lord in the time for talk is
over let us all make haste chick
night-night that's all we needed we just
needed the gallows what a hell of the
girls gonna do anyway they've just got a
sparkle in funshine
[Music]
what we do here now will be written with
swords and sorcery let us charge our
shields it use photon torpedoes to
vaporize for Klingon heaven god damn it
every [ __ ] time heaven god [ __ ]
damn it seriously that is an epic gaming
mean
[Applause]
Zach we're coming for you bad new
message from Terrence remember oh thanks
[ __ ] yeah I got a key that is pretty
impressive if you could actually do that
[ __ ]
alright let's kill the tower from the
inside me and the Pirates are gonna
scale it from the outside
oh [ __ ] we can Electrify them let's do
that okay Cartman I don't know what
you're doing but you gotta stop how are
we supposed to walk around say oh [ __ ]
are we okay a little okay what now was
that good for every gap excellent these
guys are so dead we are the Dark Lord
dude that nice side coughs douche bags
let's finish it
I'll go yet
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah
no 14 awesome okay
nice check I bear oh no they're not see
oh not the cow
nothing cow what are you gonna go with
the cow [ __ ] it done [ __ ] up okay oh
[ __ ] that from the chana yeah
not kitty kids up there the Golden
Nugget all right we need car mental life
that lives in the beginning
oh that damage not behaving they're all
immune
well it's Parliament
[Music]
nope haha next one this is this is
[ __ ] finish him
ah come on whoa there we go
not too bad not to shave it all baby
all right now I got sake is that it yeah
it is Wow indeed
where are we going now what about ah
thanks wait what the [ __ ] out of the
Pirates
I [ __ ] carmine you're too fat I'm
sorry
get over here and attack each tower and
raise the gate so we can get to clyde
lair mabel beard clear the path maple
beard oh oh all right well farts so
what'd you get all right this is what
yet sorry I guess my friend thank you so
awesome Nagasaki
similarly gate and race the gate this is
pretty badass treehouse man what can we
do here young man probe [ __ ] they got
the up at hand a sapphire that's pretty
awesome actually
that's 4c baby come on no not the cow
why do I know anything with the cows
yeah you really should have what the
[ __ ] am I supposed today okay [ __ ] and
some cows how does it calcified on his
side I guess we have no choice
poor not the cow
[Music]
okay refuse
most opie attack ever like it's good
against anything look at that [ __ ] what
what the [ __ ] like that alright hey I'll
take it
this here's a red bow the trader is
awesome you guys are missing out there's
a lot of damage
and they Jenner way let's rub all
oh we can only attack one at a time I
think it's the black one target ass
let's finish that guy up
finish that [ __ ] [ __ ]
now come on
it is him I've got bigger things to deal
with
[ __ ] you prisoner now Craig you're gonna
be somebody's [ __ ]
Clara I am alright now we can go off
right right I don't know how that makes
sense but hey I guess I'm a talent oh
it's better than Kinney [ __ ] are they
doing let me go let me down finally let
me down please
[ __ ] yeah nice armor I'll stick with my
badass Bishop it's my favorite kid
listen we're doing at the Women's Clinic
they were looking for a candidate to put
a snuke into I know these people are
claiming to be Taco Bell you should have
known should have known Taco Bell is far
too compassionate and caring to be so
secretive quality of their character
like the quality of their food should
have never come they didn't put it in a
woman thinking well this is fun but wait
is that a thermonuclear device I had
some drinks so putting a thermonuclear
device up my ass wasn't completely how
long we don't know mr. slave but it
could be a matter of minutes well what
are you waiting for pull it out no no no
pull it out don't have triggers on them
we have to abort it from
come on who knows how to do abortions
and can get really really small I can't
damn it hmm who could possibly be able
to make themselves tiny and know
something about abortion we're gonna go
up in size aren't we there's got to be
someone nope nope miss I say not today
all right breasts gonna have to end this
episode here hope you enjoyed watching
as always thank you for leaving a like
it helps me out a lot and it helps um
you from feeling all better happier so
thank you for watching brothers I'll see
you tomorrow love you brother
[Music]